bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public en étant
centre pour 90 minutes avec nos experts
à notre ambition notre volonté c'est de
donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposez des clés de compréhension des
mutations de notre société 90 minutes et
deux débats l'actu politique pour
commencer et le parti LR qui s'est
choisi un nouveau président Éric Ciotti
ambitieux pour 2027 c'est à nous qu'il
reviendra demain de porter une immense
espérance au service du redressement de
la France pour cela notre famille plus
que jamais a besoin d'être réunis d'être
rassemblés après les
4,78% de Valérie Pécresse à la
présidentielle les républicains
peuvent-ils regagner la confiance des
électeurs de droit de ce sera le thème
principal de notre premier débat où l'on
parlera aussi de la réforme des
retraites dont l'annonce est finalement
reportée aux 10 janvier et puis pour
notre second thème volontairement vous
le savez décalé de l'actualité du jour
on analysera
pour l'instant déçu des centaines de
milliers de victimes d'actes pédophiles
au sein de l'Église sur les 330
000 recensés il y a 14 mois par la
commission sauvée - 2 40 ont été
indemnisés comment expliquer une telle
lenteur réponse dans 3/4 d'heure mais
d'abord ericsiotti et sa ligne de droite
assumée à la tête du parti LR retour sur
la soirée d'hier avec Mathias Arès le
nouveau patron des républicains c'est
lui
avec plus de 53% des suffrages Eric
Ciotti a remporté hier l'élection
interne qui l'opposait à Bruno retaillod
et dès la première minute de son mandat
le député des Alpes-Maritimes à fixer le
cap on va travailler dans le moyen et
dans le long terme et on va travailler
avec un objectif gagner l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 je sais que ce
message certains pourront le regarder
avec ironie mais ce soir je leur dis que
la droite est de retour et qu'elle
assumera son positionnement d'une droite
ferme
des faits il y a un an lors de la
primaire et l'air Éric Ciotti tenant
d'une ligne dure et aujourd'hui
majoritaire à la tête d'un parti divisée
le successeur de Christian Jacob devra
donner des gages aux militants qui ne
l'ont pas plébiscité ce soir
Eric a gagné et c'est donc à lui
qu'il revient
de travailler cette unité à se
rassemblement
et bien moi j'y suis prêt
ils se sont là dès la proclamation des
résultats certains comme le maire de
Metz François Grosdidier et la
présidente de la Fédération LR de
Haute-Garonne Laurence arribager ont
rendu leur carte pour ericciotti
réconcilier sa famille politique sur les
cendres de la dernière présidentielle
s'annonce déjà comme un chantier
colossal voilà trois grands thèmes dans
ce débat les lrxi qui vient d'être élu
président parlera aussi de du Parti de
la France insoumise et des retraites
avec Claire Chartier bonsoir bienvenue
claire vous êtes journaliste et
essayiste Mathieu souquiert essayisme
bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à vous Emilia
warrial bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
docteur enseignants à Sciences Po et
Guillaume daretic bonsoir Guillaume
merci d'être à mes côtés une analyse
pour démarrer claire Chartier de cette
victoire des guilleci est-ce que ça
ouvre une nouvelle ère ou est-ce que
finalement les gens une forme de
continuité c'est à dire qu'on a un
président de parti qui n'est pas
candidat à la présidentielle on est un
peu dans la dans la même
ouest avec avec Bruno retaillot mais
c'était pas il y avait pas de question
de ligne et je dirais qu'il y a un
moment que la ligne cioti en particulier
à travers l'excellence score qu'il avait
fait au moment de la primaire que la
ligne ciotique domine en fait chez les
républicains donc ceux qui devaient déjà
partir à mon sens pour l'essentiel sont
déjà partis et il y a pas de raison qui
est beaucoup de mouvements on a cité un
ou deux noms mais on voit bien qu'on est
quand même dans les voilà les les
personnages de second rang en réalité le
parti c'est déjà réorganisé alors encore
une fois il y avait pas de problème de
ligne ce que ça confie à moi quand même
c'est deux choses c'est le fait que
désormais en fait LR s'assume à droite
et très à droite d'ailleurs Éric Ciotti
reprend le flambeau de de Laurent
Wauquiez et lui prépare la place pour
2027 donc on voit bien quelle est
l'affirmation
identitaire de cette droite la deuxième
dimension quand même qui pose question
pour les prochains mois et même les
prochaines années c'est le sujet très
stratégique très tactique du rapport à
l'extrême droite parce que en réalité
quand même dans cette élection
présidentielle le fait marquant c'est le
fait que la question de l'Union des
droites a été posée a été au centre du
débat posé par er pas résolu pendant la
campagne présidentielle mais on sait que
dans la campagne présidentielle
Eric cioti précisément avait dit très
clairement que entre Emmanuel Macron et
Éric Zemmour ou l'extrême droite en
réalité son choix était plutôt marqué et
donc ça c'est prolon la question qui va
animer la droite dans les prochains mois
et dans les prochaines années parce que
on observe que chez les sympathisants
des républicains non seulement la ligne
de droite va bien mais le tabou de
l'alliance avec l'extrême droite et de
moins en moins marqué Emilia warvial
c'est donc aussi une victoire de Laurent
Wauquiez mais est-ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est une petite victoire oui dans le
sens où même si rien ne l'indique
objectif man mais on s'attendait une
victoire beaucoup plus large avec ce
type certains annonçait même victorieux
premier tour c'était peut-être un petit
peu ambitieux mais en tout cas on
s'attendait une victoire un peu plus
large notamment parce que dans
l'histoire de la de la droite depuis une
vingtaine d'années tous les présidents
étaient très bien élus aussi parce que
il y a toujours eu une personnalité qui
écrasait les autres par sa trajectoire
et son poids politique ce soit Nicolas
Sarkozy que ce soit Christian Jacob que
ce soit Laurent Wauquiez donc
traditionnellement le chef était élu
grandement et son son son son élection
n'était pas contestée là elle ne sera
pas parce que pour une Retailleau n'est
pas forcément du genre à vouloir trop
fragmenter le parti mais il pourra tout
à fait se rappeler à son bon vouloir
durant les au moins deux prochaines
années de de son mandat faire contester
soutiens faire compter peut-être les
systèmes à lui donc oui c'est une
victoire qui est peut-être pas 100%
satisfaisante pour lui Guillaume
plusieurs cadres des républicains
disaient la semaine dernière qu'ils
avaient le sentiment qu'au-delà des
apparences Éric ce titre serait
peut-être plus souple finalement à la
tête du mouvement parce que je cite la
personne avec qui j'ai changé tellement
content de devenir président qui ferait
en sorte de finalement de faire entrer
un peu tout le monde dans la direction
et que Bruno apparaissait comme plus
rigide et venant effectivement d'une
droite un peu différente de celle
direction qui va effectivement à mon
avis avoir de difficultés la droite plus
largement c'est de croire que le pouvoir
le reviendra automatiquement dans 4 ans
et demi parce que c'est pas le cas et
que finalement le risque pour la droite
c'est presque d'apparaître comme
comptable du bilan d'Emmanuel Macron
parce qu'il y a des ministres de droite
certes plus des républicains mais des
ministres de droite au gouvernement et
puis le défi c'est de reconstruire aussi
une idéologie une pensée qui soit autre
chose que de l'antimachronisme parce que
par définition dans 5 ans Emmanuel
Macron ne pourra pas être candidat
effectivement alors regardez ce qu'on
dit le secrétaire général de renaissance
le parti présidentiel justement ce
congrès se conclut voilà ce qui dit par
les obsèques de la droite républicaine
au sein de LR c'est une interview chez
nos confrères du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France on a demandé aux adorants n'ont
pas de désigner leur président mais
directeur de campagne de Laurent
Wauquiez la droite des complexée qui se
triomphe aujourd'hui les grands gagnants
sont Marine Le Pen Eric Zemmour qui ont
enfin un marchepied à la tête de la
droite claire chattier ça pose la
question vous l'avez évoqué rapidement
Mathieu mais la question effectivement
des alliances c'est intéressant parce
que les alors là on est au-delà des de
ceux qui ont voté
si on parle des sympathisants elle est
ou des sympathisants même de la droite
ils sont favorables à des alliances mais
mais pas n'importe lesquels qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui arrive en tête quoi en
fait c'est assez intéressant d'après
l'étude fond d'Apple qui est sorti l'été
dernier en effet c'est quand même assez
partagé c'est à dire que environ 40% des
sympathisants donc pas désadérants comme
vous le disiez sont sur la ligne scioti
40% sont plutôt pour un rapprochement
avec la majorité présidentielle au coup
par coup donc là on n'est pas du tout
sur la ligne sotti et puis il y a 20 %
qui sont pour l'Union des droites et qui
est pas du tout à l'ordre du jour si on
écoute Eric Ciotti donc on voit que
c'est quand même très partagé et
d'ailleurs entre Bruno Retailleau
ericsiotti finalement il y a quand même
différence alors on sait qu'il y a une
différence sur les questions culturelles
effectivement bonheur et taillot sur les
questions sociétales marque sa
différence mais il a aussi marqué sa
différence d'une certaine manière par
son positionnement vis-à-vis de la
majorité c'est à dire que quand même au
Sénat rappelons-le le Sénat a voté et
donc les députés aussi LR qui sont
majoritaires au Sénat ont voté pour le
projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables ce qui est quand même un
signe
en tout cas de bonnes volonté ce qu'on
entend pas du tout chez ricksioti donc
il y a quand même un positionnement en
tout cas une stratégie qui semble assez
différente là où ça se complique
d'ailleurs d'un point de vue extérieur
c'est que d'une certaine manière Bruno
Retailleau si on va regarder donc le
rideau en dessous se rapproche plus de
Laurent Wauquiez enfin dans son dans son
profil c'est là où ça devient très
compliqué analyser c'est vrai dans sa
trajectoire dans son profil dans sa
culture il est beaucoup plus proche de
leur en Wauquiez que Xavier Bertrand
enfin vous voyez c'est donc c'est vrai
que c'est assez compliqué mais dernier
point sur l'extrême droite parce que je
trouve que c'est quand même important
Éric Ciotti pense que d'ailleurs il le
dit que effectivement elle est réussira
à ce à se réaffermir et à à nouveau
attirer des gens qui sont partis du côté
du Rennes en étant justement en
affirmant en s'affirmant comme vraiment
de droite pour reprendre son sa phrase
or à mon avis c'est une erreur d'analyse
parce que il fait fi de la mutation
d'extrême droite française c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec 12
extrêmes droites une extrême droite
neomoracienne qui est quand même assez
lilliputienne puisque erg Zemmour a fait
7 % donc ça représente pas grand chose
mais qui est plutôt celle vers laquelle
vous le rappeliez Mathieu Éric Ciotti a
attendu la main donc et là effectivement
on sent qu'il y a des points de
conversance et puis il y a l'autre
extrême droite qui elle néo boulanger ce
qui est celle de Marine Le Pen qui est
effectivement très sécurisé anti
migration mais qui est aussi qui a su
parler aux classes populaires et c'est
là le point totalement de divergence
profonde entre LR et cet extrêmement
atteint c'est que LR ne parle pas aux
classes populaires moyennes or c'est
crucial aujourd'hui puisque les classes
moyennes sont affaissement c'est
vraiment la clé de des situations de la
situation politique donc on ne voit pas
comment avec cette stratégie là LR
pourrait retrouver des électeurs qui
sont passés chez Marine Le Pen ça n'a
pas de sens en revanche ça peut
accentuer les divergences au sein même
de LR et je pense qu'elle continue à
exister d'une certaine manière certains
disaient que des cadres de LR
allez rendre leurs cartes siautis pas
c'est bon on va voir si si ça va se
vérifier mais en tout cas il y a quand
même un mouvement de fond à l'intérieur
qui à mon sens mais pas tout à fait
terminé warrial si on compare LR alors
là vous venez de le faire avec le
rassemblement national mais même avec
son prédécesseur c'est avec l'UMP c'est
un parti idéologiquement c'est un parti
qui se
rati nous sera ici comment on peut
l'analyser oui je pense en effet parce
que le quand même le projet du MP à la
base c'était de rassembler même si en
réalité c'était déjà assez proche mais
trois droites qui étaient la droite
gaulliste ou poste gaulliste à droite
libérale qui était hantée notamment par
la Madelin et les démocrates chrétiens
centristes même si bon il a ils ont
échoué totalement
s'accaparer l'UDF et donc il y avait
quand même l'idée qu'on avait un parti
un peu large quoi qui allait grosso modo
des conservateurs jusqu'au jusqu'au
Centre-Est très libéraux et qui a tenu
jusqu'en 2012 que Nicolas Sarkozy même
avec sa droit tenter quand même de
conseiller toutes ces composantes et
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on voit c'est
que les plus libéraux en tout cas
modérés
centrisent qui ont pas forcément envie
de parler d'immigration et de sécurité
d'identité toute la journée sont soit en
retraites soit chez Emmanuel Macron et
que reste des gens qui sont même encore
plus à droite que pouvaient l'être la
droite il y a quelques il y a quelques
il y a quelques années parce que il y a
tout un processus avec Sarkozy Wauquiez
Copé etc de décomplexions et de volonté
de ne rien céder à la gauche qui en fait
s'inspire beaucoup plus quelque part de
de Marine Le Pen que de que de que de
Chirac ou de Pasco de n'importe quelle
figure de droite auparavant donc oui il
y a une forme de rétrécissement et avec
et je dirais une relation ambiguë parce
que à la fois ils veulent que vous
l'avez dit redevenir le grand parti de
gouvernement qui gouvernera presque
seule la France et en même temps ils ont
l'air d'avoir presque accepté que il ne
pourrait pas reconquérir lectorat modéré
aujourd'hui qui est parti par exemple de
Fillon à Macron en 2022 et de d'accepter
qui seront plus qu'une petite droite
mais sans coalition ce qui veut dire au
pouvoir de la coalition si je vous
comprends bien voilà mais tout en tout
en prétendant l’être donc c'est ça reste
un petit défaut stratégique là en tout
cas c'est tout le paradoxe on sait la
fondapole la très bien montré que
l'opinion c'est droitisé une partie de
la droite c'est extrême droitisé mais
globalement l'opinion française c'est
droitisé c'est pas spécifiquement
français c'est une tendance qu'on
observe dans à peu près tous les pays
européens donc il y a ça et pour autant
la droite effectivement politiquement
est faible et faible comme jamais et là
effectivement plusieurs difficultés
devant elle alors il y a l'Union des
droites dont on parlait cette espèce de
poil à gratter tactique qui peut la
gêner jusqu'au bout mais au-delà en fait
de cette dimension il y a un vrai
problème de de d'insins sincérité et
d'incohérence me semble-t-il pour une
raison très simple il y a six mois il y
a eu une élection présidentielle Valérie
Pécresse était la présidente le
lendemain de la présentation du
programme par Emmanuel Macron celle-ci
avait dénoncé le plagiat avait crié au
hold-up donc en réalité
en réalité pour partir le programme des
républicains il s'applique aujourd'hui
la droite en réalité elle est au pouvoir
alors encore une fois je parlera tout à
l'heure quand on sera sur le thème des
retraites
qui déjà en fait le disait au printemps
et on politique la cohérence ou la
sincérité c'est fondamental ou plus
exactement l'incohérence et
l'incincérité en tout cas ces pieds il y
a une deuxième dimension le contexte a
un peu évolué pour pour la droite
c'était assez facile pendant une
trentaine d'années la Vulgate était
simple c'était moins de puissance
publique moins de dépenses publiques et
puis le contexte aujourd'hui est un peu
différent on a redécouvert le poids de
la puissance publique à la faveur des
crises qu'on a traversé pour le covid
c'était très net la puissance publique
était là et la dépense publique a coulée
à flot et là face à ça en fait la droite
avait pas grand chose à raconter et je
dirais même que on s'est rendu compte
que après avoir réduit les dépenses
publiques pendant plusieurs décennies
l'hôpital était en crise la justice
était en crise la police était en crise
donc y compris sur les grands sujets
régaliens sur ceux sur lesquels la
droite peut être à l'aise c'est
compliqué et puis la deuxième dimension
très forte aujourd'hui dans le contexte
dans le pignon c'est la transition
environnemental désormais tout le monde
comprend que on va devoir y passer on va
devoir la faire il me semble quand même
que les républicains sur ce sujet sont
culturellement très loin du ballon c'est
à dire que c'est une révolution
politique idéologique qu'ils n'ont pas
du tout fait ça ils le savent parce que
quand vous échangez notamment avec le
rang Wauquiez qui un petit peu quand
même le phonet de d'Éric Ciotti dans
cette dans cette campagne
il regarde comme d'autres beaucoup ce
qui s'est fait à l'étranger ça c'est
intéressant même quand on échangeait
pendant la campagne avec Valérie
Pécresse lui on a regardé par exemple
comment David Cameron avait réussi à
ressusciter les les conservateurs après
la période Tony Blair qui était un petit
peu c'est un petit peu rapide de dire ça
mais qui avait réussi un peu cette ce
passage sur une gauche plus libérale par
rapport au vieux parti travailler ce
Britannique il regarde aussi pas mal ce
qui se fait en Floride du côté de Ron De
Santis en disant c'est pas du Trump t'as
progressé du Trump light c'est un peu
différent et il regarde ce qu'il avait
fait le chancelier autrichien Sébastien
Kurtz estimant que ça peut être aussi
une voie de réflexion c'est à dire un
chancelier de droite qui était très dur
sur les questions d'immigration et
d'insécurité mais très en pointe aussi
sur les questions de transition
écologique en assumant de dire
effectivement il faudra qu'on ait un
autre discours et à droite on entourage
de l'envoquais ils disent ça sera pas
peu les lumières mais oui il faudra
qu'on dise à nos électeurs de droite par
exemple que il faudra manger moins de
viande que ça fait partie effectivement
de la refonte idéologique profonde alors
justement ça tombe bien parce que
j'allais parler du travail fait ou non
fait après la défaite de de Valérie
Pécresse je vous propose d'écouter pour
lancer cette dernière séquence sur la
partie LR de notre de notre débat celle
qui était sa porte-parole lors de la
campagne présidentielle Florence
portilly la mère de Taverny
c'est bien ça confirme la dynamique en
plus c'est une très belle participation
des militants et ça c'est plutôt
rassurant des gens ont un espoir de
retour de la droite et il faut plus il
ne faut plus briser ses espoirs je crois
qu'on a un pays qui est majoritairement
à droite au niveau des idées quand on
regarde les sondages d'opinion soyez
principaux items qui touchent la société
française c'est sincèrement des items
idéologiquesment qui penchent plutôt à
droite et en même temps on a un parti
politique qui n'arrive pas à incarner
justement cette espérance de droite il
faut qu'on y arrive Chartier ça n'a pas
encore été fait est-ce que les leçons je
peux poser la question comme ça de la
défaite de Valérie Pécresse quand même
très lourde ont été tirés c'est surtout
qu'en fait ils sont quand même
extrêmement coincés enfin c'est ce qu'on
vient de dire c'est à dire qu'ils ont
ils sont vraiment là enfin dans un dans
un carré extrêmement réduit on parlait
effectivement de cette droite plus
centriste alors ils sont obligés de se
démarquer enfin comme il faut qu'ils
existent ils sont obligés de se
démarquer de Macron tout en étant
finalement d'accord sur pas mal de
chantiers mais ils sont absolument
coincés c'est à dire que ne peuvent pas
la voir puisque sinon ça veut dire ne
pas exister en tant que tel donc ils ont
vraiment un champ extrêmement réduit de
l'autre côté chez Marine Le Pen à la
réussite à capter ce secteur de
l'électorat ce segment qui est les
classes moyennes dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui est essentiel donc ça va
être très difficile là de remonter la
pente ils n'ont pas compris en fait bien
avant Valérie Pécresse ils n'ont pas
compris qui se jouait là quelque chose
Xavier Bertrand l'avait compris mais il
était un petit peu il faisait cavalier
seul et puis on sait ce qui m'est arrivé
mais c'est le seul qui a un petit peu
saisis cela si vous voulez d'ailleurs
pour reprendre les exemples étrangers
lui avait regardé il a lu David Godart
etc il a compris tout l'enjeu donc ils
se sont retrouvés avec une mauvaise
analyse en amont et effectivement sur la
question écologique je rejoins
entièrement ce qui a été dit là ça fait
quand même des années qu'on pointe chez
du côté de la droite son manque de
réflexion là dessus son manque de
positionnement parce que beaucoup à
droite voit cette question enfin la
moque même en disant que finalement
aujourd'hui ah mais certains bien sûr on
les entend encore alors peut-être pas
officiellement comme ça mais les écolos
les écolos qui nous embête enfin je veux
dire ces histoires la question
environnementale c'est une histoire
d'écolo comme si ça suffit
comme si on devait pas être tous écolos
il me semble qu'ils n'ont pas fait elle
leur conversion effectivement réelle
écologique donc tout ça mis bout à bout
comment voulez-vous qu'il tire enfin je
veux dire il y a un énorme chantier de
l'environnement
il faut il faudra beaucoup de temps et
là je rejoins on aurait taillot qui dit
il faut peut-être réfléchir aux idées
avant de désigner le leader parce que
tirer les conséquences de ça c'est un
vrai travail de fond quoi un tout
dernier mot est-ce que vous est-ce que
on peut faire le parallèle entre ce qui
arrive au parti LR et ce qui arrive aux
parties socialiste oui alors du coup
avec 5 ans de 50 décalage mais qui est
fait aussi de la stratégie d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est-à-dire qu'il a d'abord
choisi d'aller siphonner électorat de
centre gauche et puis peut-être aussi
par je ne sais pas sur si personnelle ou
en tout cas y compris l'influence des
gens qui l'a recruté qui sont quand même
du coup parmi ces principaux cadres que
des gens de la droite ou en tout cas
dans le dernier quinquennat Darmanin le
maire Philippe etc bon bah ils se sont
retournés vers électorat de droite et en
se disant que bon on allait laisser
filer quelques centres gauche mais on a
récupéré cette ectorat qui finalement
aujourd'hui est plutôt aisé plutôt
âgé aussi qui qui est pour une forme de
modération et de de rigueur etc enfin
des choses d'une droite finalement
modérée comme comme avait pu l'incarner
certains il y a 15 ans y compris sur
certains aspects ni quoi Sarkozy on est
mentionné quand même compris des vérités
de renouvellement et d'aller chercher
certaines de leurs de la gauche mais oui
il y a ce phénomène là et ça montre
aussi que les anciens partis confrontés
à des nouveaux clivages des questions
écologiques de mondialisation
d'immigration etc sont un peu bloqués
ils tentent d'en copier certains ils
hésit ils sont pas conséquents dans leur
choix je pense à l'écologie ou il y a eu
des vrais réflexions en fait mais qui
sont jamais tenues jusqu'au bout à tous
les niveaux et donc c'est un peu ça le
problème et du coup on voit que comme le
PS ils vont sans doute pas disparaître
parce que voilà ils peuvent se maintenir
à 5% mais la question c'est ce qu'ils
peuvent encore peser et là c'est plus
difficile à dire allez on va parler
maintenant de du parti à les fils la
France insoumise Guillaume d'Aret
tension et noms d'oiseaux depuis 24
heures alors déjà est-ce que vous pouvez
nous résumer en deux mots ce qui est en
train de se passer faire simple même si
elle est pas toujours manuel bon parc et
des bras droit de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
a été élu effectivement dans sa
circonscription comme débuté et nommé
coordinateur du mouvement à la place
d'Adrien catenin ce qui est c'était mis
en disposition qui avait été écarté
suite à l'affaire qu'on connaît tous il
sera entouré d'une direction manuel
Bompard mais dans cette direction ni
Alexis Corbière ni François Ruffin par
exemple ni Rachel Garrido nique
lamentinota un enfant parti le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça ne leur
fait pas plaisir purge crie d'ailleurs
plusieurs d'entre eux qui dénoncent une
absence de démocratie interne et même un
repli et un verrouillage c'est ce qui
estime clémentinottin dans une interview
qui est parue chez nos confrères de
libération
est-ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon leur a
répondu OUI et visiblement il l'a lu
Thomas c'est interview dans Libération
visiblement en colère il a d'abord tout
simplement poster un commentaire sur le
compte
Facebook de clémentine Autun là où elle
avait publié justement son interview je
le cite toute la une pour nous salir
écrit l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle et puis un peu plus tard
sur son blog et bien il a balayé toute
critique je le cite pour se distinguer
autant Brie et dans l'action et la prise
de parole sans se sentir obligé de
dénigrer les autres dit-il c'est parfois
ce qu'on entend à l'école qu'est-ce que
cela dit de lefi tout simplement ça
monte déjà combien elle est fille est
associée à la personne même de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et combien c'est finalement le
talent politique et oratoire Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a permis jusqu'à
maintenant en tout cas de maintenir
ensemble des gens qui sont parfois très
différents ça montre aussi combien est
très difficile de bâtir l'avenir d'un
mouvement politique quand l'avenir de
son leader Jean-Luc Mélenchon en
l'occurrence est assez incertain car
même s'il dit qu'il n'a pas envie d'une
nouvelle candidature en 2027 il ne ferme
pas tout à fait la porte ça dit aussi
vous allez me dire que c'est comme ça
dans tous les partis et ça montre bien
les égaux qui peut y avoir au sein de la
France insoumise c'est pas un secret
qu'on sait que François Ruffin il y a
une bonne partie des proches de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qu'il estime qu'il la joue un
peu trop solo comme on dit en politique
ou dans le sport et puis ça traduit plus
largement je trouve une forme aussi
d'incompréhension de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
à l'égard certaines évolutions autant on
peut noter qu'il avait parfaitement
saisi l'évolution et le virage
écologique qui avait à prendre pendant
la campagne présidentielle d'ailleurs on
voit qu'il y a beaucoup de jeunes on le
voyait dans les meetings qui avaient été
touché par la cause de la défense de
l'environnement qui était présent à la
France insoumise autant on a pu voir au
travers de l'affaire catenas qui avait
une incompréhension du virage féministe
avec un mélange de la sphère privée une
affection ça peut être tout à fait
normal pour Adrien catenas mais en
revanche une difficulté à la séparer de
la sphère politique on voit là aussi
qu'il a une difficulté à comprendre
cette demande de démocratie y compris
interne qui a à l'intérieur de son
mouvement et quand vous échangez avec
les autres partenaires de la France
insoumise au sein de la nuque que ce
soit les socialistes les communistes ou
les écologistes et bien ils cachent pas
que évidemment d'une certaine façon il
se réjouissent de ces difficultés
rencontrées par le mouvement de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il considère comme
omnipotent et dont ils estiment qu'il
pourra se garder ses leçons c'est ce
qu'ils m'ont dit plusieurs d'entre eux
est-ce qu'on peut merci est-ce qu'on
peut parler d'une crise tient claire
Chartier est-ce que la France insoumise
est en crise ça a tout l'air en tout cas
en effet parce que c'est quand même
étonnant ils ont un nombre de inédit de
députés et il se trouve confronté à un
cumul de difficultés et là ce qui est
intéressant c'est que en fait il y a une
difficulté nouvelle elle est évoquée
dans l'interview conventionnée dans
Libération qui me semble intéressant
c'est à dire que vous avez d'un côté
François Ruffin qui a dit récemment dans
une interview à la presse qu'il était
social-démocrate alors il faut savoir
que en disant cela c'est pas simplement
ça fait l'érotiques c'est une petite
provocation victime qui paye pas mais en
fait c'est plus compliqué que cela parce
que en disant cela en fait il s'opposent
au cheminement même de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le revoilà qui au tournant des
années des années 2000 c'est tourné vers
le populisme de gauche parce qu'il y
voyait là elle a sorti de l'IMP que
constituait une sociale démocratie à
bout de souffle donc pour lui
précisément il s'agissait de tourner le
dos à la sociale démocratie donc on a
François Ruffin qui qui dit cela donc là
c'est quand même assez assez étonnant
d'un point de vue vraiment plus
théorique et idéologique politique en
tout cas c'est l'esquisse d'une autre
ligne et en face vous avez donc
clémentinottin qui elle tient mordicus à
ses combats intersectionnels
c'est-à-dire que croisons effectivement
disons que les discriminations se jouent
à plusieurs endroits qu'il faut qu'elle
se cumulent dans la vie etc et qui a pas
que les inégalités sociales donc et à la
raison d'ailleurs ça a fait le succès
d'Alessi ça c'est certain sauf que ces
combats là finalement ça rassemble une
portion de l'électorat mais pas une très
large portion de l'électorat non plus
d'un point de vue sociologique donc
c'est impératif de cumuler les deux donc
on a là déjà une divergence donc c'est
quand même alors s'ajoute à cela
l'affaire cadenas c'est effectivement
des difficultés il y a vraiment la des
réponses différentes au sein de alefi
face à la question des violences
sexuelles dans le parti une conception
différente je pense exactement une
conception différente alors il tente de
se sortir de ce marigot elle est fine
notamment manuel Bompard en disant
qu'ils sont un mouvement ils ne sont pas
comme les autres partis sauf que c'est
là aussi un peu plus compliqué que ça
parce que comme vous le disiez alors le
mouvement en fait ce mouvement là c'est
aussi au sens de la science politique un
parti personnel quand même parce que il
tourne autour de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
s'agissait pour les filles de mener son
leader au pouvoir quand même et en plus
on a un Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
effectivement on ne croit pas une
seconde qui va se consacrer ces travaux
d'écriture
laisse la porte quatrième si je ne me
trompe pas en fait un leader qui est en
coulisse derrière le rideau rouge ce qui
a crédit l'idée que il y a un double
fond donc c'est absolument terrible pour
pour l'image que renvoi et les filles et
puis Matthieu Zucker moi je vois quand
même là alors c'est l'actualité qui
voilà c'est c'est peut-être une
coïncidence de l'actualité mais on a à
côté de ça deux parties qui désignent en
faisant voter les les militants leur
secrétaire général ou leur président
pour la France insoumise on l'a pas dit
pardon mais il y a Europe Écologie Les
Verts qui viennent désigner marine
tantale Europe Écologie Les Verts dans
quelques dans quelques semaines le PS le
Front national le rassemblement national
pardon la fille il y a quelques semaines
faut dire en réalité la France a soumise
apparaît comme le seul parti politique
pardon le seul mouvement politique qui
ne respecte pas en fait ces règles
démocratiques de base donc je pense que
ça peut se payer pour le coup assez cher
je pense que c'est une crise qui est
dont on n'a pas fini de de parler en
l'occurrence alors c'est pas quelque
chose de totalement neuf rappelons que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est la République
la République c'est moi et c'est pas une
phrase anodine c'est une phrase dont un
tout le monde se souvient et qui deux a
marqué la dégringolade de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en matière de tradimage dans
les enquêtes d'opinion ce qui ne l'a pas
empêché de de revenir à un niveau assez
alors de la dernière présidentielle
attention de bénéficier d'un effet de
vote utile à la présidence on est
d'accord c'est un contestable en
revanche en matière de tradimage dans
les enquêtes d'opinion depuis la
République c'est moi on ne sait jamais
refait la cerise si vous me le permettez
il y a des sympathisants de gauche qui
ont voté pour lui au premier tour de
cette présidentielles tout en étant pas
dupe de son rapport à la démocratie
c'est un peu ce que vous les expliquez
la moitié dans mon souvenir je crois que
c'est 46 ou 48 % des électeurs de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon au premier tour qui
conteste le rapport que ce dernier
entretient la chose démocratique et
c'est sûr que donner le spectacle de ce
weekend quand on est le parti qui prône
l'institution d'une Assemblée
constituante l'instauration d'une
sixième république qui depuis 5 ans en
fait n'a ne cesse de dénoncer la dérive
autocratique autoritaire du pouvoir à
coup de gilets jaunes à coups de
conseils de défense pendant le covid
c'est compliqué on est quand même en
pleine contradiction
je voudrais bien savoir Emilia owardiale
comment elle est fille est organisée
vous l'avez un peu évoqué mais c'est il
y a pas de courant comme au PS de la
grande époque quoi c'est ça marche
comment non et je veux dire que
justement le parti était créé pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de courant d'accord une
structure très très flexible très
gazeuse on peut dire ça aussi gazeuses
comme ils ont dit alors il y a un
poétique qui s'appelle manuel Server
Marzal qui a fait toute une sociologie
de la France insoumise et qui publie pas
d'une structure en oignon alors qu'en
fait il y a plusieurs couches
successives et donc il y a un centre et
donc comme chaque couche est indépendant
de combat les cadres locaux peuvent
fonctionner indépendamment etc mais à la
fin du fin c'est toujours le chef qui
décide et on voit que en fait elle est
fille les gens peuvent fonctionner assez
librement mais si à un moment donné
quelque chose qui déplaît par exemple
une une un petit peu un petit peu
contestataire ou s'il y a une phrase un
peu malheureuse au niveau local et ben
on peut avoir les équipes y compris mais
tout à fait informel et et et et et et
officieuse de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
vont venir régler un peu les choses et
donc et même les gens avec Mélenchon n'a
pas de statues en fait dans le parti
autre que en fait d'être l'objet de ce
parti la partie était créée pour
soutenir Jacques mais alors là si je
reprends
l'image de l'oignon on est en train de
on se raccource enfin on se réduit au
cœur de l'oignon quoi vous voyez en
quelque sorte c'est-à-dire que en tout
cas dans la nouvelle instance dirigeante
et ça pique les yeux l'oignon quand on
les framboise j'ai hésité à faire toutes
les blagues à l'oignon je vous je vous
laisse là on est d'accord ça pique les
yeux la crise la crise ne tombe pas par
hasard aujourd'hui enfin précisément
Jean-Luc Mélenchon quand même qui était
l'homme fort de la présidentielle avec
22 % a fait le choix de ne pas se
représenter à la députation et donc de
ne plus être au cœur du jeu politique
aujourd'hui et deuxième dimension tout
se joue à l'Assemblée alors que
désormais tout se joue à l'Assemblée il
est sûr qu'il le regrettable et deuxième
dimension on en parlait à l'instant
depuis l'automne l'automne a été
difficile avec l'affaire 4 minces et
l'automne précisément et l'affaire 4
minces ont montré la césure qu'il
pouvait y avoir entre Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dont la posture et les déclarations ont
été très mal perçues et le reste du
mouvement et dernière dimension
effectivement le mouvement pèse
aujourd'hui 85 députés de mémoire 85
députés qui sont de jeunes députés de
nouveaux députés que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ne connaît pas qui ne connaissent pas
Jean-Luc parce qu'il le croise jamais à
l'assemblée par définition font
aujourd'hui leur vie politique
indépendamment de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
donc il est évident que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sans que une partie le pouvoir
qu'il avait lui échappe et donc ce coup
de force aujourd'hui n'est pas le fait
du hasard c'est précisément où il se
sent affaibli il essaye de reprendre la
main sur le mouvement après il y a une
vraie césure aussi idéologique notamment
avec François Ruffin qui a quand même le
premier dit à l'issue des législatives
on a eu un résultat correct mais qui
était pas celui attendu parce qu'on ne
parle pas aux classes populaires
c'est-à-dire on ne parle pas parfois
d'immigration ne parle pas de sécurité
et ça c'est une vraie rupture c'est
finalement un discours qui se rapproche
de celui de Fabien Roussel mais c'est un
vrai virage qui est assumé de la part de
François Ruffin qui n'est pas celui du
reste d'une partie de la France
insoumise et puis Emilia houariale on
peut se poser la question des prochaines
échéances électorales est-ce que les
filles peut progresser lors de ces
élections sans sans finalement au
contraire chercher à élargir sa base ou
ça ou ça ou ces lignes politiques vous
voyez ce que je veux dire je veux dire
que d'abord si on parle des vrais
prochaines élections bon il y a les
européennes mais surtout aussi les
élections locales ils peuvent pas faire
pire que durant les cinq années
puisqu'ils avaient quand même avant pas
réussi à s'implanter localement et en
fait il va se poser la question que se
pose pour tout ce qu'on appelle les
parties mouvements c'est-à-dire ces
parties qui sont à la fois de vraies
parties qui présentent des candidats etc
puis en même temps très habile
c'est-à-dire de s'institutionnaliser
donc ça veut dire avoir des cadres
locaux avoir des vrais relations
régulières avec ses partenaires et aussi
se poser la question puisque les
échéances pour beaucoup c'est 2027 de
pourquoi est-ce que malgré tout ils ont
pas réussi à avoir cette ni compris
cette qualification et en plus qu'ils
avaient sans doute très peu de chance de
l'emporter et ce qui a pas des thèmes
sur lesquels il faudra se questionner y
compris qui t'a peut-être déplaire un
petit peu au leader sur l'international
sur le covid sur sur plein d'autres
sujets en tout cas et ce qu'il y aura
pas quelque chose pour aussi parler aux
gens qui sont dit bah non je préfère
quand même voter PCF pseld voilà
qu'est-ce qui manque c'est bien beau de
croire qu'il y aura un élan comme ça qui
poussera le le Mélenchon ou quelqu'un à
la présidence et que tout découlera de
ça mais on voit bien que ça a des
limites et que ils peuvent aussi vouloir
mener des combattre et localement dans
des mairies dans des régions et il va
falloir du coup se structurer un petit
peu plus au sein de la nuque
manuellement discuter avec la nouvelle
secrétaire nationale marine tondeuillier
qui a été élu ce weekend en remplacement
de Julien Bayou écoutez là elle veut
d'abord se concentrer sur son parti là
on va prendre le temps parce que si on
le prend pas maintenant il sera trop
tard et donc pendant quelques mois faut
nous laisser tranquille avec la news
faut nous laisser tranquille avec les
polémiques on va travailler au grand
mouvement de l'écologie mais pas en
autarcie pas pour notre hégémonie on va
le faire parce que c'est ce qu'on a de
mieux à faire pour les écologistes pour
l'écologie pour la gauche et pour la
France mais on va continuer à se parler
bien sûr qu'en janvier on sera ensemble
dans la rue pour défendre nos retraites
on va en parler dans une minute mais
peut-être un mot mais rapide parce que
le temps a filé Mathieu souker
c'est clairement enfin c'est la nuque la
nuque c'est pas le plus important enfin
voilà il y a une stratégie qui est
clairement affichée là oui alors il se
trouve quand même qu'il y a deux parties
de composantes de l'anus qui
effectivement ont eu un automne
difficile les écolos ça a pas été
tellement plus simple qu'à la France
insoumise donc on en est là encore une
fois les électeurs l'électorat a
rattrapé en réalité les différents
partis de gauche à la présidentielle
toute la gauche est partie désuni au
scrutin alors même que il y avait dans
l'opinion une forte demande d'union de
la gauche c'est ce qui s'est traduit
d'ailleurs de façon très empirique très
pragmatique par le vote utile en faveur
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon en épi des
préventions que je rappelais d'une
partie de son électorat une partie de ce
qui a constitué son électorat mais on en
est toujours là en réalité c'est à dire
que l'opinion de gauche reste
majoritairement acquise à l'union de la
gauche on considant qu'il n'y a pas de
gauche d'irré-conciliable en tout cas
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion démontrent
bien que les différentes composantes de
la gauche y compris la France insoumise
à 80% reste encore une fois très
partisanes d'une union de la gauche à
l'inverse en face les boutiques si
j'osais dire en tout cas les partis
politiques demeurent on crée dans des
logiques un peu boutiquières un peu
corporatiste qui sont de décorréler des
attentes de l'opinion allez on va parler
de notre troisième thème la réforme des
retraites Steve Jourdain vous pouvez
nous rejoindre puisque on pensait
qu'elle allait être présentée cette
semaine par le gouvernement encore raté
encore à thé encore un théorie car on
l'attendait pour le début de l'automne
mais elle avait été repoussée une
première forme nous l'a lancé en grande
pompe pour la fin de cette semaine mais
surprise Thomas cela dit Emmanuel Macron
a décidé de faire durer encore un peu le
suspense le chef de l'État ouvrait la
deuxième étape du CNR le Conseil
national de la refondation et il a
ouvert comme ça s'était tapé pertinent
de décaler de quelques jours quelques
petites semaines
l'annonce de la finalisation de la
proposition du gouvernement et donc au
lieu d'opter pour le 15 décembre me font
ça le 10 janvier voilà d'ici le 10
janvier les concertation doivent se
poursuivre Elisabeth borne reçoit cette
semaine les chefs des groupes
parlementaires pour le Sénat c'est
Éliane assassin la présidente du groupe
communiste qui ouvre le bal aujourd'hui
ensuite ça sera autour des syndicats et
du patronat
avec les syndicats et les partis
d'opposition il reste donc trois
semaines pour dessiner cette réforme il
va falloir aller vite très vite sinon
sinon certains points se régleront
peut-être dans la rue Thomas merci Steve
pour tous ces pour tous ces détails
quand j'entends tout ça ça me fait
toujours penser à cette phrase d'André
Bergeron qui était le secrétaire général
de Force Ouvrière il y a du gras à
moudre donc peut-être qu'il y a encore
du grain à moudre c'est une vieille
référence pardon qui ne parle qu'elle
peut être qu'un match génération mais
bon c'est pas grave
moi je vois quand même claire Chartier
dans ce report d'abord des raisons
politiques est-ce que c'est pas une
façon de je me dis mais traiter ericky
alors il y a marine Tondelier aussi qui
met le président l'a dit très clairement
là on a entendu un extrait de son
discours devant le Seigneur mais il dit
il y a de nouveau président de enfin ou
leader de parti politique il faut il
faut les entendre il faut s'en occuper
le sous-texte effectivement s'adresse
très directement à Éric Ciotti parce que
ricksiotti sur le fond on l'a dit
auparavant ne peut pas être contre cette
réforme enfin vraiment c'est tout à fait
prisonniers d'une certaine manière en
revanche ce qui est difficile pour
erikiotti et ce qui va être difficile
c'est qu'il risque de se contredire
parce que il vient d'être élu comme
précisément président d'une force
politique qui s'inscrit vraiment en
contraste par contraste avec le
macronisme donc là maintenant il va
surtout dans une situation ou si il se
démarque et s'il fait vraiment trop de
résistance effectivement il va se
retrouver dans une situation assez
inconfortable donc je pense que là
précisément Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs
il l'a dit il veut placer les
responsables politiques face à leur
responsabilité donc c'est exactement
c'est très bien qu'il place avec ce type
face à cette contradiction donc il
compte sur ce temps supplémentaire pour
certainement essayer de faire avancer
les choses mais je pense que ça va être
compliqué pour pour exciter et sur le
sur le fond il s'est assez risqué aussi
du côté d'Emmanuel Macron parce que bon
on en est pas à son premier épisode
c'est une arglaisienne à chaque fois il
a il a changé enfin il avait dit qu'il
reportait la réforme des retraites la
fois précédente parce que il y avait le
covid et après le covid aujourd'hui on
est quand même dans une crise massive
énergétique mais on va n’empêche qu'on
va quand même avoir la réforme des
retraites donc tout ça est vraiment une
espèce de feuilleton qui n'en finit plus
mais surtout ce qui va être quand même
difficile à gérer c'est qu'il va y avoir
une conjonction au mois de janvier qui
va être absolument terrible c'est à dire
qu'on va avoir donc cette fin du
bouclier tarifaire donc au synergétique
l'application la réforme de la science
au chômage elle est Fillon d'en parler
qui annonce une marche pour les
retraites le 21 janvier donc quelques
jours après la présentation du projet de
loi et il faut savoir quand même que ces
Français dont on dit effectivement qu'on
répète qui sont contre cette réforme ce
qui est intéressant en plus c'est que le
nombre de Français qui sont pour un
abaissement et non pas une hausse un
abaissement de l'âge légal a fortement
augmenté ils sont maintenant un tiers
alors qu'il y a quelques temps les
Français ils étaient pour une réforme
des retraites donc on voit bien là que
la situation s'est considérablement
dégradé parce que le contexte explique
aussi cela donc Emmanuel Macron prend
quand même un risque je pense qu'il
était un peu peut-être contraint de le
faire mais je je trouve que socialement
il prend un risque ça veut dire Emilia
warrial que même la le on va dire la les
sympathisants ou les électeurs de la
droite républicaine classique je sais
pas quel terme employé qui était plutôt
favorable à une réforme des retraites à
un allongement de l'âge légal de la
retraite ils sont en train de dire non
c'est ce que c'est ce que nous dit un
petit peu clair Chartier
d'abord le le parti lui dans son aucune
difficulté à voter une réforme des
retraites dans laquelle on sait pas
forcément encore du côté des électeurs
les républicains les acteurs
républicains on sait pas particularité
d'être souvent les plus favorables en
fait une réforme des retraites notamment
parce que c'est ceux qui sont en fait le
plus favorable à toute une forme de
rigueur budgétaire etc ne serait-ce que
parce qu'il y a des questions d'âge il y
a des des personnes retraitées beaucoup
chez LR et chez les REM qui est aussi
veulent préserver leur retraite et qui
donc se disent que une réforme est
nécessaire mais en effet je pense que
même chez frites quand même ça même chez
électeurs LR il y aura la réflexion de
quelle est la mesure de justice derrière
finalement si par exemple elle a réussi
à négocier cruellement des idées par
exemple qu'on va avoir de meilleures
retraites pour les agriculteurs les
anciennes femmes au foyer etc ça pourra
être peut-être négocié et passer chez
ectorat mais si c'est perçu juste comme
une mesure budgétaire on met tout le
monde à plus trois ans de travail là ça
pourrait mal passer y compris chez les
électeurs les plus favorables à priori
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il n'y a que les
retraités qui soient majoritairement
favorables à la réforme des retraites or
il se trouve que les retraités
constituent ce qu'il reste de
l'électorat LR donc on comprend bien en
fait la traduction politique de tout
cela oui une partie une partie de
l'électorat de Macron mais mais en
réalité les choses sont désormais assez
tranchées donc quand même Emmanuel
Macron le président de la République
engage une réforme des retraites qui est
globalement rejetée par l'opinion qui
est en toute état de cause rejeté par
l'ensemble des syndicats mais def mise à
part la gauche là pour le coup sera très
uni sur cette histoire de la réforme des
retraites la difficulté de c'est que il
s'est fait élire deux fois et à chaque
fois sur une réforme des retraites
différentes celle de 2022 2023 n'est pas
du tout celle de 2017 celle de 2017
c'était une réforme CFDT compatible la
réforme la réforme à points la retraite
à point pardon c'était précisément
quelque chose que Laurent Berger
défendait depuis très longtemps la
réforme qui est présentée ici c'est
typiquement une réformé l'air c'est
celle que porte la droite classique
depuis des années et des années en 10 64
65 ans Édouard Philippe lui qui se
positionne 10 67 ans aujourd'hui même
pourquoi pas 67 ans alors on comprend
pourquoi un Laurent Berger par exemple
s'y oppose 67 ans ça veut dire que la
personne qui a commencé à travailler
très jeune à 16 17 18 ans ou même 20 ans
va travailler très longtemps si elle
doit tenir jusqu'à 67 ans et j'ajoute un
dernier élément globalement quand même
beaucoup de gens sont opposés à cette
réforme y compris les économistes qui
avaient contribué au programme
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 Jean Pisani
Ferri et Philippe à Guillon qui était
donc ces deux économistes de l'époque on
aujourd'hui pris fait tes causes contre
cette réforme en
sur le fait que d'autres paramètres
pouvaient éventuellement être modifié
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment du grain à
moût qu'est-ce que vous y étiez à
l'Élysée ce matin faut pas exclure non
plus que ça soit il y a pas que ça mais
aussi une réponse à ce qu'a dit François
Bayrou ces derniers jours quand même un
partenaire de pour ça une journée du
dimanche d'ailleurs à déplorer hier dans
le journal de dimanche je cite qui est
pas eu assez de pédagogie je crois en
fait au niveau collectif alors dit-il
depuis plusieurs années mais on voit
bien que c'est aussi la majorité
actuelle qui est ciblée il dit depuis
des décennies les Français n'ont jamais
été suffisamment informés pour se forger
une opinion voilà et quand vous échangez
avec son entourage aujourd'hui ou lui
demander si le président du MoDem est
satisfait que ce qui s'est passé vous
dites ils vous disent à votre avis donc
la réponse la réponse est assez claire
il y avait aussi une hypothèse qui peut
paraître farfelue qui était de dire
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron a voulu jouer
d'un effet coupe du monde c'est-à-dire
on est au cœur de la Coupe du Monde
est-ce que finalement il a préféré
reporter les choses en se disant je
préfère jouer c'est 15 jours de fin
d'année sur une atmosphère plus positive
d'autant plus si les Bleus l'emportent
bon je trouve que l'argument est un peu
léger et surtout les réversible parce
que comme l'explique plusieurs
conseillers d'Emmanuel Macron vous
pouvez dire aussi qu'il aurait pu faire
la réforme des retraites présenter les
pistes des 7 semaines qu'on en parlera
pas trop parce que tout le monde aurait
la tête à la Coupe du monde mais je
pense qu'il y a vraiment le truc central
quand vous échangez avec son équipe
officiellement il dit les nouveaux chefs
de parties en réalité il y en a pas un
qui vous parle de marine tondelei ou des
autres c'est on veut mettre la pression
sur les républicains et qu'ils viennent
nous expliquer effectivement comment ils
peuvent refuser de voter une réforme qui
était à peu près celle de Valérie
Pécresse et effectivement c'est ça
illustre bien ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur la difficulté de
reconstruction et idéologique des
républicains quand vous échangez quand
vous discutez avec Eric suti ou avec ses
proches aujourd'hui vous dit sur le
principe je ne suis pas opposé à une
réforme des retraites mais Emmanuel
Macron procrastine mais Emmanuel Macron
prend trop de temps donc on voit que à
un moment voilà le pari de d'Emmanuel
Macron de dire très bien mais que
pensent les républicains oui ou non
est-ce qu'ils voteront cette réforme et
c'est ce qui rendra le début de l'année
2023 passionnant merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat bientôt
évidemment sur sur public